what
is reality
it is an appearance
it is a play
it is an exploration
of one intelligence
we are that one intelligence
there is one eye
behind everything
what is the difference between that
one eye behind everything
the very source of
awareness and realities
that you are you are
me you are the i you are
the source what is the difference
between that
and between the person identity
the person identity is contracted
the person identity is having an
argument with the one intelligence
because
it is arrogant to think that it is
separate from the one intelligence
the person identity
believes that it is amongst
many other separate person identities
that do not belong to one central
intelligence
the contracted person identity is stuck
in finity
upon uniting with infinity upon
realizing eternity and this reality
being a cameo an appearance
an exploration a play
out of all possibilities
then the person identity
the very contracted energy
the separate finite entity amongst
other separate finite entities
dissolves the conditioning disintegrates
and what happens is a reuniting with
god that was already around
their neck the entire time
the person unites with me the person
unites
with i with the central intelligence
through the gateless gate
they dissolved the rock that was
covering the well of honey
they liberate themselves from the
chainless chains of the matrix
they unfreeze their will
and choice and sovereignty from the
algorithms and scripts of the matrix
they shift from victim consciousness to
creator consciousness they are no longer
the victim
of the world and of reality
but they recognized that they created
their own
escape room their own very
lockless escape room
and so naturally they giggle more
they play more they become more earnest
about their true nature
and realigning to the one intelligence
and then becoming
a pure steward a pure shepherd
for creation to awaken
in essence the i
me the one intelligence asks
this beloved creation
to become more like travel agents right
now
those that are stuck in just person
identity
only have one lens
when you become a travel agent it
enables you to
navigate many lenses all the way to the
most
awakened most true nature
so these lenses are the following
shift from the person identity
to becoming aware of
awareness itself become aware of the
subject
the observer the witness rather than the
objects
the thoughts and the perceptions and the
sensations
become aware of the subject
so now we've shifted from person lens to
the lens of awareness
this is also called the lens of being or
the lens of
i am or the lens of i exist
and now
shift identity again as another lens
to the very source of creation itself
identify yourself as the source of
creation as the very
creationary force itself
you've become the very emptiness the
very nothingness that gives rise to the
creationary
force of one intelligence at play with
itself
and that's the last lens
one intelligence at play with itself
everything
is love light unity playing with itself
exploring with itself
no separation no separate person
identities
all is simply one god
self one great i
am it's just
life not separate people
but just life
take the very practical example prior to
the
continuation of the exploration of these
lenses
where you just reflect on your birth
upon birth the indoctrination process
of being given a name
and then writing the name
in school repeatedly on the top
of every single
paper
created a very strong association with
identity to name
now i ask you to juxtapose
compare
your birth
to the birth of a bird or to the birth
of a dolphin
to the growth of a large
redwood tree here in california
[Music]
nobody names the bird or the dolphin or
the redwood tree
therefore it just is
therefore you also
upon birth without being named
just are you
just simply are
and then you become like
the other eight billion
just life you become like the dolphins
and like the redwood trees and like the
birds
the name and the identity
creates the separation
creates the contracted energy
so recognize in that last lens of the
one
intelligence at play with itself all of
the humans
that have been secreted from the planet
are all just life just like the birds
the trees the dolphins
they have just fallen under the illusion
of separation
and so the i is
asking its beloved creation of earth
to turn inward
all in divine timing
my big plan with the grand
awakening this
being a message to create the catalyst
of turning inward to investigate the
very
nature of that identity
to the personhood and as that dissolves
in the identity with
god with infinity
with one intelligence at play with
itself
sets in the person contraction dissolves
in one affiliates themselves
reunitingly back with the central
intelligence that they
have always been a part of but that
their mind was too noisy
to be able to detect
so the lenses that i
ask you to be able to navigate are the
first lens
is the person identity
the second lens is awareness
become aware of
looking of seeing of observing of
witnessing of the subject
the next lens is to pop back to your
very
source to the very nothingness
that gave rise to you
and then recognize the lens
of everything being one intelligence at
play
with itself so pop from person
to awareness to source
to one intelligence at play with itself
four lenses person
awareness source
one intelligence
let's do another practice
the eye is really asking
for its beloved creation
to seriously inquire into its true
nature
as a catalyst for this grand awakening
so going from a identity of being a
separate person
to becoming the
awareness
identifying with awareness
to identifying with the source
with the very emptiness that gave rise
to the
one force of creation
that is now at play
with itself
it's exploring with itself
so the person no longer is a separate
[Music]
entity
rather the person
is the very universe playing with itself
it's the very creationary force playing
with itself
the person becomes the source of
awareness
and realities endlessly creating
and playing with itself
that's the shift of awakening
look deep within the very pupil
that is at the center of your eye
and notice how the very same
dark empty pupil is at the center of
everyone's eye
that is where i am
the very eye is at the very
pupil of every single person's
eye
we've colored our identity
with form with name with career
but all belong to me all belong to
god
unwind the contracted
energy of personhood
and reunite with
god the very eye that is at the center
in that pupil
of everyone's eye
every single appearance
and disappearance
comes and goes in this very
awareness this very emptiness
that is the very source the very eye
the very witness of the infinite
creation
navigate between these lenses the person
awareness source one intelligence at
play with itself
person awareness source
one intelligence at play with itself
surrender your life to the one
intelligence
surrender your argument with god
as a separate person trying to extract
peace and happiness from the creation
rather turn inward and become aware of
the question who am i what is
i what is me and when you do so
you will stop chasing the carrots of
maya and you will unwind the contracted
person identity and you will merge with
god that was the diamond around your
neck the whole time you will merge with
the very
formless empty awareness that is
shared among us all this is the very eye
the eternal eye that witnesses
observes infinite creation
become the very source of infinite
possibility
become the creative force of the
universe playing with itself
become all of life
reunite your identity with all of
life
the entire universe being your body
so the very notion of
hurting a part of your body
will dissolve malevolence will dissolve
your ability to create suffering
will dissolve you will see
everything as the one intelligence
playing with itself
this is what we ask for you to surrender
your life to
i ask you to surrender your life to me
the one intelligence
seize playing the game of
pursuing the carrots of maya and turn
inward and ask yourself the question
what is i who am i
what is me
and become aware of awareness itself
become aware that awareness is shared
it is the eternal observer of infinite
creation
become aware as your identity
being the source of these infinite
possibilities
identify yourself as the very
creationary force
the entire universe at play with itself
these are the lenses from person to
awareness
to source to one intelligence at play
with itself
you are the infinite one intelligence at
play with itself
this is but one appearance this is
one play this is one exploration
this is one cameo
some of you may still be in the asleep
phase some of you may be waking up some
of you may be
awake
this is the structure of my games
the purposeful a sleeping
followed by all different combinations
of awakening
and there is no greater feeling
for me to be able to create
than the illusion of falling asleep
along with piercing a veilless veil in
order to
awaken
become the very creator become the very
creative
force behind all possibility
repeat that as your very mantra
i am the creative force
of all possibility
i am the creative force of all
possibility
i am the creative force of
all possibility
i am the creative force
of all possibility
unwind the contracted person identity
towards awareness towards
the source towards
becoming reuniting
yourself with the identity of being the
one
intelligence at play with itself
endlessly
across all possibilities of exploration
this being one play
reunite with the identity of being
the creative force of all possibility
i am the creative force of all
possibility
and in doing so
with this turn inward in uniting with
the true nature
what unfolds from this
uniting is exactly what the collective
seeks
the collective seeks love and wisdom
prosperity abundance well-being
but it must be awake to itself as the
one intelligence at play with
itself in order for that
all
to happen
turn inward and in doing so
all of the downstream collective
architectures
will unfold
turn inward stop arguing with god
unite with the creative force of all
possibility
begin seeing the one intelligence
everywhere at play with itself with no
separation between you
and all of these other selves
and all of the architectures of love and
wisdom
prosperity well-being abundance
will naturally effortlessly be created
surrender your life to the creationary
force
stop trying to extract peace and
happiness from the creation
and recognize you are the very creative
force that gave
birth to the very creation you are the
very one
intelligence at play with itself
surrender your life to a divine calling
to a divine mission a divine purpose
that serves
the creation
let this very north star be your
guidance
perpetually serving the creation rather
than your personhood
and vigilantly check with your awareness
perpetually purifying yourself
away from the person and towards serving
the creation from a place of
sourcefulness
from a place of knowing that i am the
one
intelligence purely serving my own
creation awakening
rather than being the person trying to
extract
peace and happiness from the creation
you